Blizzard released diablo 2 almost a full  16 years ago in two thousand and they  just gave it a new update no you haven't  fallen into a time machine I'm Tony and  this really is a gamespot news update  update 1.14 a is the first patch for  diablo 2 since 2011 and it's meant to  make it run more smoothly on modern  computers according to blizzard there is  still plenty of diablo 2 players out  there and this update will let them  continue to play the RPG they love you  really do have to admire blizzards  dedication this may not even be the  final diablo 2 patch blizzard is still  working to prevent cheating and hacking  and considering the sequel diablo 3 sold  over 30 million copies the developer has  plenty of RPG players to please whenever  Blizzard announces the next patch you'll  hear about it from gamespot